okay
I'm with unlocking the truth Jared
Malcolm and Alec
where's my how old are you guys 13 I'm
14 I'm 14 and you are part of a metal
van how did that get started years ago
back in 2007 uh me and Malcolm started
like in wrestling shows tell me I guess
you know over this mic and everything so
so Mia Jarrett started watching
wrestling and Japanese animated music
videos or whatever and then the
background music was metal and I guess
we liked it and then when I work I lost
are looking at metal bands and then I
liked this man call disturb and I went
to see them live and that's when I
realized I wanted to be in a band
I grew up whatever and how old were you
at that time I was seven he was six so
you guys formed a band when you were
basically seven yes that's crazy people
might look at three young black kids
growing up in Brooklyn and think you
know they would have wanted to be emcees
or do hip-hop not metal tell them why
they're wrong the reason why they're
wrong is because it's not all about the
race or the color of your skin it
matters on who you are and who you feel
that you can be I don't think it's
racist but it is how people stereotype
in their heads you know just because
we're black doesn't mean we have to rap
you know everyone comes on different
cultural backgrounds and it just
happened that we just came from good
households each one of us where our
parents are open to the idea of
exploring and learning new things
Malcolm I've heard people compare you
guys to the Jonas Brothers obviously
your mother
but what do you think about that this is
gonna be honest answer musically we're
just people compares to the Jonas
Brothers but yet we're so different from
them cuz we play heavy metal a daily
more of a lighter do that again Alan put
his head into care
what was it like to have a film crew
follow you around all the time and tell
me a little bit about that experience it
was challenging at first it was a bit
challenging well after a while we got
pretty used to the cameras following us
around and then you know we just got
after we got comfortable it just became
natural and um the footage as you see in
the film is raw like we're not acting or
trying to like do takes like they'll say
Alec why don't you do that again like we
never did any of that like all of it
just pretty much fell into place it was
like as if they weren't recording like
we did everything as if we were just
being our normal natural selves that's
our that's the real uncut unlocking the
truth as you see in the film being
portrayed and that's how we want to be
portrayed so so if you look at your
career like 10 years down the line
you're gonna be 24 at that point what do
you hope to see I don't know what I want
to do act now I want to be a successful
band and I'll be producing music and
yeah producing and still making music
madam yeah
Co modafinil su musica